- So a bunch of Redditors on
WallStreetBets have coordinated
to inflate the stock price
(air whooshing)
of GameStop, trying to
basically bankrupt a hedge fund
that has the opposite position.
Who cares? YOLO!
But is this legal?
Well, generally you can't conspire
to set the price of
anything, let alone stock.
And there are generally
two types of things
that the SEC really likes to
put a stop on. (air whooshing)
One is fraud.
You can't lie about a stock
to try and inflate the price.
And two is what's called
market manipulation.
Illegal market manipulation is defined as,
"To affect a loan or one
or more other persons
a series of transactions and any security,
creating actual or apparent act of trading
in such security or raising
or depressing the price
of such security for the
purpose of inducing the purchase
or sale of such security by others."
Market manipulation is a very squishy term
that's very hard to decide
because often you're buying a stock,
hoping that others will buy it as well
and inflate the price.
(air whooshing)
But just because a bunch
of Redditors are doing it
for the LOLs doesn't
mean it's not illegal.
It depends.
(air whooshing)
And this one could go either way.
And that's why you should only
buy orange juice concentrate,
pork bellies, and gold bullion.
And I'll see you in court.
(bell dings)